- What kind of mad fart
- I don't know.
was that loud
but also sounded far away?
(laughting)
(upbeat horn music)
- Hi everybody, so, welcome to The Closet.
I'm Jen, that's Niki.
Today, we're gonna talk a
little bit about personal style,
specifically, how your style might change
after you come out.
To talk about this, I
have my friend Ashly here.
Ashly, you wanna come on, crawl in
through the closet side door.
- Yeah, I've always seen it
online, but I didn't realize
how cramped it was til I was here.
- Nah, it's crampled as fuck.
- Should I just sit like this?
- Is that comfortable for you?
- I don't know.
- Okay.
(laughting)
- Hi Jen.
- How are you?
- I'm good.
- Tell me a little bit about yourself.
What are your pronouns, what's
you're favorite thing to eat?
- My name is Ashly, my
pronouns are she, her.
- Cool.
- For a second I forgot
what pronouns were,
I was like, fuck, they are she, her.
And my favorite thing to eat is soup.
I love a good soup.
- What?
- Yeah, everyone is weirded out by that.
If I could eat only one
thing it would be soup.
There's so many kinds.
There's stews, there's
soups, there's like,
different flavors.
- But, soup?
- Yeah, I like soup, in short.
And I'm gay.
Well, what am I, I'm queer.
- Queer? Okay.
- That's cool.
- After I came out as queer
I went, like, every way
on the style spectrum.
I was like super masculine,
super feminine, like chapstick, lipstick.
I was in a sorority before,
and so, like, everything
was super feminine and I
always remember feeling, like,
really awkward about what I was wearing
and my clothes and that kind of stuff.
And so after I came out I was like,
"Oh, good, I can finally be myself."
But it was funny 'cause I was like,
"I don't know how to be gay," and so I
bought a bunch of snapbacks and button-ups
and Vans and stuff and that didn't feel
completely right either.
- You bought Niki's wardrobe.
- I bought Niki's exact wardrobe.
I did the easiest thing I could
do, was just copy clothing.
- And then I was, like, exposed to more
and different types of
queer women, and I was like,
"Oh, they kinda all just
have their own style,"
so, I didn't have to do
it one particular way.
Did you cut your hair after you came out?
- I did.
I cut my hair during
the same year I started
really fully dating and just being out.
- Did you feel more comfortable afterward,
or were you a little
scared, like, "Oh, man."
- Now everyone knows.
- I did it, like, 'cause I
was, I wanted the convenience
of not having long hair.
When I was younger there
was so much of trying
to hide people from knowing I was gay.
When I cut my hair I was like,
"Oh, am I letting them win?"
Feeling like yourself.
- Yeah.
- Being able to get to a
place where you can feel
like yourself in your clothes
and also be comfortable
with everyone seeing
that you are yourself.
- Being a queer person
kinda complicates that,
but I also think it's kinda cool,
you get to paint your own palette
and decide what makes you comfortable.
It's hard to sit in
this closet for my back.
Let's talk about back
issues in the closet.
- Y'all know this game.
It's called Spin the Bottle.
We ask a question, we spin the bottle,
and then whoever it lands on
has to answer it honestly.
Have you ever farted during sex?
Here we go!
- Jen!
- Me!
I feel like, yeah, I've farted,
but it's never been noticed.
One time the girl I was
dating at the time farted
and I felt so bad because
I didn't immediately
identify it as a fart.
- Oh my God.
I didn't know it was a fart,
so, like, I jumped, and I
was like, "What was that?"
Like, I sounded really offended.
If I had known it was a fart
I wouldn't have said anything.
I felt like a book
shelf fell, so I, like--
- It was that loud?
- It was like, pretty loud, but I--
- I mean, it can get precarious down there
'cause depending on
where you are you might
be really close to someone's lower parts.
- Oh, yeah.
- And then it can get, like, caught.
- Yup.
- Like, between, like,
bed sheets and your face.
What's the grosses thing
you've ever done. Niki?
- I don't know.
I will, like, regularly pick boogers.
- Oh, that's disgusting, Niki.
Get the fuck out.
Anyway, thanks for coming to The Closet.
- Thank you for having me.
It was real fun.
- [Niki] Yeah, thanks for coming!
- This was great, be
yourselves, little queer angels.
Yeah, don't open that.
- Don't open, don't.
- Open it and drink it.
- Don't, don't.
- Oh, it didn't do anything.
- It so immediately smells
just like pure orange.
That expired two years ago.
- Should we leave the closet, Ashly?
- Yeah, let's leave the closet.
- All right, we're gonna leave the closet.
- Good-bye, friends.
- Bye!
Thanks for being gay and nice.
Okay. Cut!
- [Ashly] That was fun!